welcome back everyone um we are
um we have another exciting session as
you probably have
experienced this morning that we have a
really introductionary conversation
going on and that's wonderful we have
two talks in this session the first is
from jd who is talking more from
slightly more technical
perspective we will find out
and then we have chris o'neil who will
be talking about human in the loop um
we will be the talks are
15 minutes and i will give you five
minute warning
somewhere here
um
if for the audience if you have
clarification questions feel free to
raise your hands during or right after
the talks but we will keep all the more
discussion
um the discussion kind of questions
to the end after both talks so with that
i'll hand it to jd thanks sorry did you
say 15 minutes 15.
cool all right thanks
uh
hi everyone my name is jd
i'm very happy to be back at uh
in the cluster i was out last week
unfortunately um
i'm going to talk to you today a little
bit about a project that i've been
working on
in partnership with chanyang
from cornell tech and richmond wong
who's a postdoc here at berkeley for the
next month before he goes off to start
his uh assistant professor gig at
georgia tech which is very exciting
um so all the great ideas
in this talk are due to china and
richmond and you can assign any
sub-optimalities to myself
um all right let me start
by
talking about large language models or
llms
um i'm sort of curious for a show of
hands of like who has heard of
large language models okay so you've
probably heard of like gpg3 and
some of these other things would it be
helpful
to give a little bit of context some
examples of like what exactly i'm
thinking of here yeah okay
so
uh language models are sort of this
older technique or by older i mean
several years decades depending on how
you measure it but essentially they are
models that predict based uh text based
on prior text so you have
a corpus of data
you have a training set that you've used
to set up your language model previously
you feed in that initial prompt that
initial set of text and then you ask the
language model
what text comes next and it provides you
with a bunch of additional text there
are multiple different formulations of
language models
the large language models that people
are using today tend to have this kind
of structure but there are also versions
of it where you can ask it to insert
text in the middle and some other things
like that
um large language models have very many
parameters so they are much larger than
the
language models of several years ago
and in particular gpt-3 and this is sort
of of the class has about 175 billion
parameters which means that if you were
to try to store this in one place right
it would require you roughly 175 order
of 175 gigabytes of data to store it so
they're much larger than
prior models and this scale
provides new capability in some sense
and
i would say
there's a bunch of discussion about how
true this is
whether or not is the scale that
provides it and you know does this does
this as we continue to scale are we
going to continue to see increases in
capabilities i think these are all
interesting and open questions but not
quite the focus of my talk
but what they do provide currently is at
least some set of capabilities that i
think are quite interesting and they
provide generated text that is highly
fluent and in many cases contextually
valid
um but it has somewhat limited reasoning
ability and it can often just be plain
wrong so there was a lot of hyper on
these models when they first came out
people were like oh like you know here
we have something almost sentient blah
blah blah and that's like no we don't
but but they do have interesting
capabilities that i think are worth
exploring
um and i'll look at these a little bit
more in the talk so
i thought it might be helpful to look at
some examples here is a
a prompt
so your interface to a large language
model can be as basic as this right you
have a text box and you say these words
this is your input into that large
language model
you know write a creative ad for the
following product to run on facebook
aimed at parents here's the product and
it will give you some copy
right and this is like there's no
specific training for this large
language model in copy producing other
than text that might exist in the input
data set right in the training set
um so if you've seen this kind of stuff
before you're probably not very
impressed
if you haven't seen it before you might
be a little bit surprised to learn that
it in fact is fluent english text right
and it looks like you might actually use
that kind of
copy if you were imagining designing
something like this
there are a bunch of other examples here
uh
there is like
fact based q a that these that these
language models can engage in that's
pretty fluent
there is
uh
there's also sort of fact based um
like an essay outline for example
so showing that there is sort of some
capability
for recall of like facts about the world
in these models
that can be drawn upon
by writing a prompt in a particular way
here's another example
why not
why not indeed
i'll give one more example here
this one is a little near and dear to me
because chad and i have another project
in which we are trying to build chatbots
based on these large language models and
it is let me tell you it's exciting
but i won't be talking about that today
all right so
what i want to talk about now that you
have a little bit of hopefully of a
flavor of what these large language
models are we'll talk more about the
capabilities in just a second
is ubiquitous accessible large language
models and so this is in a sense
a regime in which large language models
are much more accessible
than the existing nlp tools are today
so right now if you're a company like
facebook or google or whatever you can
hire legions or phds in nlp to do a lot
of the same things you can produce
fluent text
you can you know do all sorts of
analysis et cetera
but you need relatively large
institutional support to do that
relatively large degree of expertise
and i think that this accessibility is
going to be
relatively key and interesting to
explore
so i think it will plausibly enable far
more accessible use of those specific
capabilities
and in particular
i'm not saying this is good or bad
what i want to explore here is i think
it's coming and i want to understand
what some of those effects are going to
be
so that we can either
mitigate them understand what to do
about them or at least steal ourselves
for the future um
i'm less concerned about
current institutions using large
language models because i think again
they sort of have some of these
capabilities already and there are
governance structures that sort of
handle that
you know to better or worse degrees
and i'm more concerned about the sort of
let a thousand flowers bloom
accessibility
of
individuals or small groups of actors
that
you know are the same sorts of people
who inhabit 4chan who desire disruption
who want to engage in trolling whose
idea fun might be like
ddosing a 9-1-1 service i'm more
interested in people who have goals of
pretending to be more people than they
are and and so on
so we'll talk a little bit more about
that
in just a minute
um
and so in this talk
uh what i'm really asking is can we
predict some of the interesting
second-order effects
of the accessibility
and
large-scale like ubiquitous use of large
language models as a platform
and i don't really have an answer here
but i am planning on drawing examples
like smartphones
smartphones essentially enabled
uber and
rideshares is a platform
the sort of work doesn't end at 5 pm
nature
that sort of comes from the ability that
the human plus smartphone platform has
to be tracked at all times you know
where people are you know that you can
communicate with them
sort of enables these kinds of
applications that live on top of these
platforms that can have pretty
transformative effects
um social media has sort of a some has a
similar effect you know obviously it has
many effects but another one here is you
know ubiquitous reviews and people have
sort of this trust in the things that
they read
you know five stars means it must be
good right and maybe this is fraying but
i think it enabled a certain set of
um existing
uh applications that we use today things
like airbnb
and the gig economy
all right so
talk about my motivation let's look at
some llm capabilities
some lenses for considering impact and
if we have time we'll do this a little
mini workshop although this may just
devolve into the q a we'll find out
and then perhaps i'll share some
insights so the capabilities that in
particular i'm looking at
are a few that we've mentioned earlier
so fluent directed text generation and
interpretation
conversions between text and structured
data and one way that i've been thinking
about this is sort of conversions
between
the types of things that humans
typically produce when they're thinking
about things
and the types of data that are most
useful are most commonly used in machine
algorithms
rapid automatic deployment right so the
ability to sort of once you've got a
process in place just make it happen
many times quickly
and then natural language based
instruction following this is
essentially the ability for humans to
describe a natural language a desired
outcome and to have the computer so try
to take steps in
producing that
i want to share a couple lenses that i
think might offer an interesting way of
taking those capabilities forward
so this i would say the most common lens
i'm not going to i hesitate to call this
obvious but i do think it's the one
that's seen the most play is this
sort of lens as uh
large language models there's an
opportunity for time saving automation
right
so this is for example
um automatable tasks are now done
quicker and without or with more limited
human involvement
right so you know who
what human tasks will be automated like
who will be out of work uh whose
experiences will be less personalized or
re-personalized like how much energy
will this use things like that i think
people have been asking these kinds of
questions
to some degree of fruitfulness recently
i'd like to propose a couple more lenses
um the first one here i think of is
labor of love
so instead of shaving time
off of the completion of a task instead
of doing the task quicker
you might want to use a large language
model to compute the task
better so one example of this might be
in authoring text right so there's a
bunch of prior work looking at large
language models to augment the human in
a writing task right and i think
actually someone in this workshop worked
on this paper
in other words can you use a large
language model to provide suggestions
for yourself so that you can then have
more of a curatorial
relationship to the tool rather than an
authoring relationship you're sort of
looking at suggestions and using those
in generating your own text
some examples of this in poetry using
large language models to generate text
that's used for inspiration or ideation
and perhaps the more uncanny valley side
of this there's uh importing a deceased
loved one's writings or uh chats or sort
of historical messages and then using
the large language model to sort of take
that to the next level and have a
conversation with that person right with
sort of the large language model
impersonating
the deceased loved one
um
this i couldn't help but include this
but i think of this lens a little bit as
giving a [ __ ] as a surface you feel part
in my language here um in other words it
is a way
to show that you care to do something
uh rather than saving yourself time to
continue to invest that time but to have
a better outcome
okay
the second one here uh second lens i'll
talk about is the system one system two
analysis
this is where you're using a large
language model a little bit uh in the
sort of i should say sorry system one
system two in a like conomon sense of
like you know rapid versus slow analysis
um using large language models to help
you make decisions
so one one example of uh system one
would be you know can i use a large
language model to figure out what i want
for lunch right here's what i had the
last several weeks what should i have
for lunch today there's also the sort of
system two version of this which is a
teacher asking perhaps is this a good
paper here are some examples of good
papers here are some examples of papers
and you could absolutely just pipe this
into the interface that you saw earlier
and get an outcome of like yes this is a
good paper here are a bunch of reasons
why
and obviously you know i'm sure you can
think of some of the effects of doing
that kind of thing
uh the third lens here is uh sort of
more human than human
um this is inspired by some recent work
that we saw from
kashin
at cornell tech using large language
models to deceive by pretending to be
human
so large language models are capable of
generating text that seems more human
than typical human text
sort of could be used for impersonation
of known people
you'd be used for deception
for example political attacks feigning
popular support
um and things like that all right i
suspect we don't have time for the mini
workshop at this point
we'll call it okay
so um i offer these as sort of an
opportunity a way of thinking about uh
i'll put this on here and maybe we'll
get to it at some point perhaps during
the cluster but um
you know i think i i offer these as a
way of thinking about
what are the kinds of questions we
should be asking about how people might
use large language models in the future
under the assumption that they become
relatively relatively ubiquitous and
accessible
so i'll be writing a paper about this in
the next couple weeks but hopefully
you
wanted
so what i what i was yeah so what i was
thought i could do um
was have you all actually pick a domain
that is familiar to you
and um
you know something work related hobby
related whatever think about the
capabilities that we described earlier
think about these lenses
and and try to figure out if you can
think through you know what kind of
thing might someone use these
capabilities for
given that particular lens in that
particular domain
and what are some of the outcomes of
doing that kind of thing right and i
sort of sprinkled some examples
throughout the talk of things that i
thought were interesting but i would be
curious if you all
have thoughts on this as well
all right how's that good okay
thanks
thank you and we are
um next is chris coming up talking about
humane the loop
hey